so today i'm going to talk about vitamin
k2 and some of the functions that go way
beyond just dealing with bone formation
we talk about vitamin k2 most people
associate that with making your bones
more solid and also removing
the soft tissue calcium from the joints
or the arteries and then driving that
into the bone and vitamin k2 works with
vitamin d but vitamin k2 does a lot more
as far as the function of bone ghosts
we might think it's just a structural
scaffolding to hold everything together
but bone not only provides a structural
function
but it's vital in making immune cells a
lot of your immune cells originate from
the bone marrow but there's another
interesting function your bone acts as
an endocrine gland it makes a hormone
called osteocalcin
has to do with a hormone that can affect
your blood sugars and it just so happens
that vitamin k2
triggers
this
hormone
so vitamin k2 has the capacity of
improving insulin resistance and when i
say improving insulin resistance i'm not
talking about worsening insulin
resistance talking about making it
better because vitamin k2 can increase
insulin sensitivity and there's so many
people on this planet right now that
have a problem with insulin resistance
without being aware of it
so vitamin k2 can help stabilize your
blood sugars and increase the output the
production of insulin
from your pancreas but it does other
things as well it has the capacity to
suppress
inflammation
vitamin k2 is an anti-inflammatory
vitamin we know vitamin d is
anti-inflammatory but vitamin k2 can
also help as well
now number four
vitamin k2 can decrease fat accumulation
why
because it helps to
balance insulin all right number five
vitamin k2 can also increase the
capacity of energy in your mitochondria
when you exercise now i have some
personal experience on this one right
here
when i take vitamin k2 30 minutes before
i go on a bike ride i have much better
endurance especially going up hills and
number six it can even increase
testosterone now realize if you're
female
it's not going to increase testosterone
beyond your normal levels okay so it's
just going to help balance testosterone
now let's talk about the foods that are
high in vitamin k2
nato which is fermented soybeans
butter if it's grass-fed
yolk as in egg yolk
goose liver
pepperoni of course without the nitrates
salami without the nitrates
sausage
sauerkraut
and certain cheeses
like monster cheese gouda brie another
one being edim and hard cheese the key
is grass-fed cheese now if you look at
some of these foods like nato and
sauerkraut
k2 is made by a bacteria it's part of
the fermentation process now if you look
at some of these other ones they're
either coming from an animal fat
or milk or an egg but the animal
originally ate grass which has a lot of
vitamin k1
and then converts it to k2
as a fat soluble vitamin and it gets
stored in the fat for more information
about k2 check out this video right here